[Music]
myanmar is a country in free form a coup
in february derailed democracy sparking
mass uprising and a brutal crackdown by
the authorities
security forces are accused of murder of
sexual and physical assault
of torture with our team in myanmar this
is our investigation into abuse in
[Music]
meet custody ton
the engineering student dreaming of
going to japan
the clever son
the adored friend
just 21 years old
in february he was at college in central
myanmar
then the military staged a coup
three months later
cinco ton
is dead
as protests against the general's power
grab surge
zinko tun joins rallies in mandalay
posting his defiance on social media
this is the start of his resistance
a resistance that led to arrest
and death
he couldn't accept the detectorship and
give his future to the gentile
he was in the first line of defense ko
yanwin knew zimko tun well
as with all the witnesses in myanmar in
this report we've changed his name and
voice for protection
by may zinko tun had joined an armed
group of volunteers fighting junta
forces
during one battle
he's shot
captured and taken away by the
authorities
this is the last known picture of him
alive
holding his injured right arm
he was arrested as an insurgent
so the military will torture him
definitely
one is lucky they're only beaten in
there and released with some wounds
but most are injured for life after
being arrested and some die
news of the fighting in zinkotan's
village is on military tv the night of
his arrest
the six captured alleged terrorists are
the same group pictured under the tree
but only five are in these photos
zinkotan
is missing
the next day zinkotan's family is called
to collect his body
ko yanwin saw his corpse
there were wounds on the body which are
the signs of being tortured
when i found the injury on the back of
his head the area was really soft
i found some injuries around his abdomen
and lips
his bhagata the federation of twin
union's tattoo had also been removed
from all of the people that we've spoken
to who knew zinkotan and also from the
photos of his body that i've managed to
see there's a definite suggestion that
something violent has happened and i
mean if i look at this photo there's
string around his wrist why is it there
but the problem of course is that i'm
not an expert
and that's why we decided to contact the
professionals
we contacted physicians for human rights
who asked a forensic pathologist to look
at our evidence
dr karen kelly gave us a detailed report
he was a previously healthy 21 year old
the gunshot injury appeared not to be
life-threatening
because there are photos of him with it
bandaged and alive
and
so to me this would indicate that there
was some element of homicide
to this death
that would be my number one concern is
that that he was actually a homicide
death
how confident are you in your belief
that this was
a homicide
oh very confident and those most likely
responsible for the death are
those who arrested and held him captive
that would be my opinion yesterday
[Music]
isn't the only one to allegedly die in
the custody of myanmar's security forces
like him
others were dead after just a few hours
this is poet ket t
he died less than a day after his arrest
his family say he was tortured
then there's opposition politician kin
mung lat
he died in custody after just one night
friends say his body was covered in
injuries
officials claim he fainted
finally activist and teacher saw me at
lynn
his wife was called to collect his body
from a military hospital
state media claimed he fell on a steel
pipe trying to evade arrest
these are just four of the suspicious
deaths that we know about
campaigners believe there are many more
so we find that the
the military junta is using a systematic
campaign to terrorize its own people and
attack its own people and that includes
arrest and detention and beatings in
custody
this is a man
famous poet
and he
was detained along with his wife
and held in custody for one night
and his body was returned to the family
the next day and was there any
reason why he might have died in custody
did he have any health problems
his relatives said he was in good health
and he had no health problems at all the
next day he was returned to his family
just his body and he showed signs of
torture
so you think this is a deliberate
strategy to
spread fear essentially undermine the
enemy
the janta is trying to create an
environment of fear and intimidation so
people will not speak out against the
military junta
more than a thousand people have been
killed by junta forces since february
many shot at protests
some
even gunned down in the street
thousands more have been arrested
we were forced to kneel down with our
hands on our heads in the street
they were pointing guns in my face when
they found us and i was also beaten as i
was arrested
by the end of march protests had been
happening daily
schwermann was at a sit-in when security
forces arrested her
she was then taken to one of the dreaded
interrogation centers for questioning
police officers brutally physically
violated both women and men
in the interrogation center the male
detainees building was just next to us
we were always hearing those screams and
tortured sounds
and i also witnessed one woman who was
the same age as me
there were bruises all over her swollen
face and bleeding wounds on her mouth
she took off her blouse to show bruises
on every inch on her body
many of the former inmates say they were
detained at protests
others taken from their homes at night
and then the interrogation begins
i talked with one young woman
she said she was beaten up so badly by
the soldiers when she got arrested
both the soldiers and police continued
to abuse her at the police station
like brutally kicking at the woman's
private parts
they used a police baton and a metal
broomstick to beat her up
the police even sat on her back while
torturing her
aemia was arrested in yangon
after being questioned by police she was
driven to the northern edge of the city
along this road to schwapita
interrogation center
a place synonymous with fear
it's too dangerous for our crews to film
at the site at the moment but this is
what we've managed to piece together
from former detainees there are four
main buildings all of them single story
kind of like hearts there's one for men
one for women
one for staff
and then there's this one the secluded
one
this is the one where they say people
were taken handcuffed and blindfolded
this is the one
where they say people are beaten and
tortured
all of us were brutally violated both
physically and mentally especially
the boys who were brought to the
secluded building
i didn't see anything but we could hear
the bawling and screaming
beatings by the authorities are
frequently reported
some are done in plain sight on the
streets but the women we spoke to
described systematic abuse by the
security forces behind closed doors
there was a woman
she looked a mess and there were so many
wounds
her jaw was broken also her nose and
cheekbones
and one of her eyes is black but she
could see
there were bruises everywhere especially
on her buttocks
this is the woman amir is describing 31
year old kenya ii
a dancer who trained in the uk
she was arrested at home hours after a
series of bombs had exploded at a nearby
local government office the next day
military run tv aired details of her
arrest
accusing her of being a bomb maker
but look carefully
something is very wrong
this is king a2 less than 24 hours after
her detention
you can see her face was
almost unrecognizable
the amount of swelling
and bruising
are consistent with significant blow to
her face and how did you and the family
feel when you saw that photograph what
did you say to each other when you saw
it
very upset very very very upset and very
worried about her
we were worried that her life
could be in danger
stop killing protesters
now tantz has been campaigning in
manchester for kenya's release
for almost three weeks her family heard
nothing while she was in the
interrogation center
then she was allowed to make one phone
call
she simply said to her mom that not to
worry about her
she is okay
in my opinion it is unlikely that she
was able to speak freely
in june state media broadcast an edited
confession where king yay two seemingly
admits to a range of crimes including
making weapons and arson her godmother
says she's surprised by the confession
and fears it may have been coerced
kenya two is now being held in the
notorious insane prison with thousands
of others
allegations of abuse continue to emerge
this is one of the largest attacks that
the junta has led against its own people
we're talking about thousands of people
being arrested hundreds of people being
killed is anyone safe
no i don't think anyone is safe in
myanmar if you're against the military
janta if you're calling for democracy
human rights in myanmar there's a
well-founded fear of arrest detention
torture in custody and even being killed
in the streets while protesting
killing torture
abuse
the military regime hasn't responded to
any of the allegations we put to them
questions over deaths and violence
continue to go unanswered
in a few short months myanmar has gone
from a fledgling democracy to a country
in crisis
since february's coup throughout our
reporting we and others have uncovered
claims of abuse and killing in custody
by police and military
those meant to protect the people
now stand accused of terrorizing them